Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Portal 2 with Patrick, also known as Shodleech, say hi.
Hello!
Hello, hi everybody! If you don't remember Patrick, he is from the Make a Wish Foundation -or he's not
from the Make a Wish Foundation- but last year I did a video uh, with Patrick, uh, telling you guys about his wish.
He wanted to be a You Tuber, and now he's been at it about a year now,  uh, so tell us how it's going!
- It's going good, I made about a 100 videos so far and
- Mmhm
I'm actually getting used to it, learning how to edit and such.
It's going better than I thought it would, actually.
- Yeah. I mean, it took me a long time to learn like all the editing stuff, like,
I wouldn't say I was an expert at it 'till 2-3 years in.
But if you guys out there watching need a re-introduction to Patrick I'll put a link in the description below:
The video we first made together when I went up to visit him in Oregon.
But for now, we have Portal 2 to play. And this isn't the campaign for Co-op, this is community levels.
Oh my goodness. What the hell is this?
-  I've never played a community level in Portal 2, let alone play co-op in portal.
-  Yeah, and the thing about community levels is that apparently they're made a lot differently
than normal levels are, because holy crap what the hell.
Okay, so I'm assuming that with this, we need to get-
- We gotta play with balls, Mark.
- Yes, I know, haha, very funny. The basis of all humor on Youtube.
If you wanna be a good Youtuber, you gotta learn how
to handle your balls. So.
- Yeah we got two of them it seems.
- No, it's just coming through the portal several times
- Yeah, my assumption...
...is that
this is suppose to pick up speed
going down. - But it doesn't seem to be a very smooth transition. So...
...I'm just going to hope for the best and then we're going to put this...maybe....shit!
Nah..it doesn't work.
THIS DOESN'T SEEM TO WORK!
Hang on..
Okay..
So..
- We got.. red...
- The enders.. yah.. ya...
- So, we have our own 2 portal sets
You have your set I have mine
-Yah yah... thats the BASIC of Portal 2, everyone knows the BASIS of Portal 2.
In fact everyone out there is automatically smarter than we are
And have already figured this level out
And we're stupid for not getting there yet- so we gotta pick up our game here
So, what we need to do is we need to get
A- at the fundamental level, we need to get the ball from...
THERE
all the way over to that platform in THERE
And this...
just means that that's gonna go there...
and that flows through
- Do we have to grab the ball?
No, I'm- I'm pretty sure we have to make the ball pick up momentum
and then roll down at LEAST twice
- Because there's one wall here
One wall there, then there's the white walls up here
- Yeah but we need to get it enough speed
So that it launches from this platform all the way up there
So
The- the basic roll through isn't enough
It's just gonna bounce around and then
fall through
So it needs-
We need to find a way to get this to pick up momentum
Or else we're not gonna get anywhere
So how do we do that??
Patrick!
- I...
- (horrible Patrick impression) I-huyhehe (Shodleech laughs)
Come up with a solution now!
- We stare at it and hope somethin' happens!
-That's NOT how anything is done
only ACTION can find our way through this
so we gotta ACT
I just need to find a better way to get this to speed up because it keeps hitting a block...
Like every single time it hits- it hits like a space...
it doesn't go smoothly from one point to the other
and I can't grab it
so
We need..
momentum.
How do we get momentum though?
- I can pick the ball up!
- Well Yeah! Congratulations you picked up the ball!
But how do we get the ball from here
to there
Because the ball can't fit through there b-
Oh
I guess it can.
Well GOOD JOB THERE,
It landed over there.
Ya really-
You're really conjuring up a storm of brain activity...
alright
- Hey at least we have something going on!
- No we have NOTHING going on!
You have less going on than what I had going on!
So just bare with me,
let the genius move through this
and you just sit there all pretty.
- Yup, I'll sit here.
- Ugh...
- Don't forget the being pretty part, because that's very essential.
- Yeah.
Okay now it's-
- Isn't it glorious?
- It's-
Ahh man.
'Kay it's kind of...
Nope, it just gets stuck every once in a while.
It'll like-
It'll keep going for a while and then it'll not...
Ah man...
- Does it LITERALLY like have to have precise
Portal pl-
As low as it can go?
- I, ah , ... you know i dunno
There's-
ugh-
There's so many different ways, like,
That... you can get speed
But thing about this design here on this level is that..
This is an imprecise structure-
They had to like fanaggle the level design to even make this work.
So
I don't know what it wants.
But what I could guess...
Is that I could at least make it go through one time,
and on the second time through...
it'll go... and roll...
and then it... hang on.
'Kay it's gonna go.
and it's gonna roll once through
and then the second time...
it'll do NOTHING.
(yelling) Yay that did nothing! We've reached no progress!
This level sucks and I hate it!
This level's STUPID, I got the ball stuck in the wall.
Gosh dangit
- That there shows your anger.
- Yeah, whatever.
My anger is nothing compared to what I'm gonna do when I break down the walls of this level
So ok- it's...
Okay, so...
Alright, let me-
let me... get here.
- Well just to ask since I've never done anything with-   - Woah.
- OO. Oh! OO OO OO. OO.
Forget- forget the idea.
Forget the idea.
Okay, watch this.
Get- get this ball outta here.
Get that ball outta here!
Get- TAKE THIS BALL FROM ME.
TAKE IT.
There we go, okay,
watch this.
I... I can pick up speed!
Okay...
so.
I need YOU to place these portals that I'm going through,
because I can't... place the outside portal.
And what you're gonna do is you're gonna place the portal on the inside of the... loopity loop.
And then I can jump through,
you can pass me the ball
And THEN I can get into place.
Okay ready?
I'm at maximum velocity go for it!
(voice cracks while screaming)
SEE?! Tah dah!!! - Tah dah.
See- See you shoved that through before by letting it go through...
And I-
oop i almost had it,
you grabbed it back... THERE we go!
DONE! And done.
See? Genius!
We're all super smart and we opened the door!
Don't you feel accomplished?
This is what it means when people are smart and do good!
- Yes I can easily tell that that is... the smartest thing we've done this year!
- Yay! Probably, at least.
Okay now you...
Tell me what you see in there, because I can't go in...
Oh.
(laughing) That doesn't help me at all.
But it's a camera - good job.
(deep breath) I don't even know what I'm doing with that *inaudible*
Okay
So I see a hole...
There's another button - there's another button-  oh my goodness...
Close to that door that you entered that area
right over here. So if you could come back and press that button,
then I can open the door behind me
and there's another button in there that probably leads -
This is gonna be fun
No no no, it's fine.
Okay. See? now you can come...
Oh.
Thaaat... wait, press that button.
Both of us press this button.
Okay, that didn't do anything.
Go through the door.
Okay. And then... just walk around the corner and you'll see me on the other side.
See? Okay, so
now it's just a... it's a physics
tilt puzzle. We have to get this ball
together... to
all of the orange dots, I believe.
That's probably what it wants, so
you wanna tilt it-  Okay so I tilt it this way-
-yeah, you've got-  - which way do you tilt it?
- I'll tilt it after it gets to the point
where I need to tilt it, but for right now, you need to-
you nee- you are in the main control.
This is like, you've got the hard job here.
So it's gonna roll...
That's gonna go through there...
It's gonna TOUCH the orange...
Nope.Okay, so we need to avoid the orange. Okay, I got it. So, avoiding the orange.
So I gotta... tilt...
Okay...got this...
Oh, this is actually really cool!
Okay, now you - Whoops!
I need to - yeah, okay. Wait...
You let go...
and theennnn I'll let go
real quick here. Ok-
No, no, YOU let go,
stay let go, and then, okay...
And then... it'll tilt...
And then you stay let go, stay let go,
stay... stay let go! Stay let go!  - Oop.
Okay... now go back on! ON! ON! ON!
ON! ON! ON!!! ON... dammit!
This is gonna be good.
Dang it. I...I screwed that up
Okay...
HUP!  -Nope!
- Eruugh! I got it. I got it.
No, no, you had it. You had it good.
You just gotta get back on.
Okay, here we go. Ooohhhh yeah...
Oh yeah, Oh yeah, Oh yeah, THAT'S THE ONE!  - (unintelligible)... Release it at this point.
- Okay...Okay...Okay...
So... Alright, so we gotta go...
All the way to the white,
Which means - okay - just
let it go down!
And then we'll just
squeeze right in there... Perfect! PERFECT!  - Yeah at this point
- it's all on you Mark, you're in control.  - Perfect, perfect, perfect, perfect, PERFECT!
YES!
OKAY! OH!
Look at this! Here have the ball.
Boink! See? We did it!  Teamwork!
- And now I should be able to go through-
or at least, you could help me get through.
If you...
Wait... how do I get out?
Help!   That doesn't help!
Stop looking at the camera! Help me get through the door.
You know the buttons before?
The important buttons...
- Oh, yeah! The buttons!  - Oh yeah, da buttons
Okay, so now it's just open. Okay.
So, yeah! TA-DA!
We got through it.
Okay, so we're both here? Oh, we did it!
Hurraay!
Okay, good job.
Oh, god! What is this?
What is this?
Okay, first-  - A complicated game, maybe.
- Uh, first step is... create a bridge,
second step is fall on the target,
third step is ball in a pit, I don't know
what that means.
But this drops a ball....  - Alright, so there's a dot above each and it just adds another dot, to-
Yeah...
Ok and what does this do?
WOAH! Hello!  - Is this another velocity one?
- That's, that's another velocity one you're exactly correct.
So you put your portals there...
Good, ok.
Now I'm going to...
I need to get up there before I can-
No, oh, actually I don't
'Cause  you can press-  - You want me to stand on the platform?
Yeah, w- let me, uh, let me just, I can just get
there we go! Whoop, whoop, oop-
There we go. Okay.
So now I can gather velocity,
but you have to launch me with the red on one of the portals
like, or one of the platforms right there
or right there. So I don't know which one,
But good luck! I'm putting my life in your hands!
- That's probably not a good idea!
I know! but go for it it's the only chance I have!
*High pitched screaming from Markiplier*
Ok! So I'm up here. That's interesting!
Buuuuuuut....
- That was step two, now step three's up there.
- Yeeah, there's nothing up here but a door I can't get through
because there's a blue dotted line... that follows...
- Oh!
- All the way to the other side  - There's absolutley nothing to put a portal up-
- Oh I was supposed to go up that side.
YOU WENT THE WRONG SIDE HOW COULD YOU!
How could you?
- Well, I'm sorry! You're the one that pointed the...
-  f... eyeball right-  - (unintelligable "that's not important" noises")
- Whatever, YOU... hang on. You gotta undo that 'cause, I- I- I'm not there yet
Step off the thing...
Okay.
Now... 'kay...
Gosh dangit!
Hup!
J- just step on the button when I'm midair.
No! When I'm midair!
HEPT!
Hept!
WHEN I'M MIDAIR! Not when I'm...
phft "sans" air...
God dammit, come on.
Work with me here.
AHHH! You're so wrong!  - (in the background) I'm tryin'!
No you're not!
Try harder!
GUHH! Come on!
And don't say I can't fit up here 'cause I'm short 'cause I'm not.
(exasperated) There we go. That's the stuff. That's a winner right there.  - (in the background) There we go.
I believed in you the whole time!
- Of course.
- OW!
Wrong portal!
*Mark Laughing*
* Mark and Shodleech laughing*
- Ow.  - (unintelligable)
- Can you, uh, - (unintelligable}
No, no, no, no, no-
How 'bout you- y-yeah there ya go.
Okay. Let's try this again, with less ow to my face.
That doesn't help.
Doesn't help, doesn't help, doesn't help.  - Still fun.
- Alright, Go!
- Go?
-  Yes!
OW! Again, wrong portal!
Why would you do that?
Okay-  - I'm gonna assume you're doin' this on purpose.
-  Three,
two,
one.
- Wee! Okay. So I need a ball up here, apparently.
-  So I needed to-  - Alright, I got a ball down here.
- Oh, so I needed to be carrying a ball with me.
So give me that.
Gimme that, gimme that, gimme that, gimme, give me.
There we go
Give!
Let go. Thank you.
Alright, now let's do this... very... challenging...
What is that- it's like a- it's like there's a- Okay there we go.
Okay, so-
Hupt!
There we go! First try! Getting good. Okay.
I'm almost full velocity, not yet...
Hold!
HOLD!
Okay, I'm at full velocity.
WHEE!
Alright! And then plodoink,
Okay, good there.
And then we just both need to go up that way.
So to do that...
- But did you see anything up there that
would let us put a portal over-
- No, no, we don't need to  go up that side,
we already got, like-  - Oh.
- see how we got the blue line is now orange, that means the circuit is completed
and the door is open up there.
- So I have to get you back up on the other side?
We BOTH have to get back up here.
- Oh.
- Yeah, so the interesting part about that is- Ooh!
There's stuff up there. Hang on. One second.
Hup.
- Oh, okay.  - Oh I didn't see that 'til now.
- Ah, this w- this would make... things...
not easier. This doesn't make anything easier.
Huh. 'Cause there's no one to stand on that...
So lemme see...  - Wait, wait- there's-
-  on the other side there's also one.
- Yeah, so what are these two?
I think these are just ledges that we could... jump through-
Thank you, I was gonna fly through that.
Could you j- Oh you greedy!
Stop being greedy!
Lemme- lemme- lemme- explore my genius
and then you can do your thing.
- Fine! Fine!
- Alright, now I'm going to put this here...
and watch this.
Hup!
Fladoink!
And-
Oh, just barely not enough! Oh no!
Oh no...
- Is there some way where I have to make that
velocity again, then you're somehow able to do that?
- I mean that should be able to do it,
it seems like that's enough. Let me just try it one more time,
maybe I wasn't fast enough on it.
Or I, maybe I wasn't precise enough, so let me try this again.
Woop.
Hup.
Woop. Woo.
Woah-kay, not quite. Okay.
This is a conundrum that we're gonna have to figure out next time we make this video, so.
For now...  - Yeah.  -we'll pause it.
But we'll get back to this in just a second.
So thank you, everybody so much for watching.
If you wanna check out Patrick's channel,
it's "Shodleech," there's a link in the description below.
And check out the video that we made in Oregon together!
So thank you again, and as always,
we will see you,
in the next video!
Buh-bye!
(Outro music plays)